We can represent these finite state machines in a variety of ways.
Let's start with a tabular form called a state transition table.
Here the rows correspond to states and there are four columns. One column for
the name of the state. Another for the input event which is going to
cause a transition. The third for whatever output action is going to
be taken upon the transition, and the fourth for the next state. That is,
the state transition table is going to capture the idea that a system in
a given state, when given a certain stimulus, and when a stimulus occurs.
Is possibly going to produce some action or response, and
leave itself in a in a state, possibly the same or possibly a different state.
To see how this works, let's imagine a garage door opening system. In fact, a,
a simplified version of my garage door opening system. Okay. It's gotta motor
and that motor can be lifting the door up, it can be pushing the door down, or
it can be stopped. There's a button that can be pressed to turn the motor on and
off. The door itself can be all the way open, all the way closed,
or stopped at some intermediate intermediate state along the way.
Importantly, the, is what happens when you press the button, and
in this particular garage door situation, okay. What happens when you
press the button can be one of three things depending upon what state you're in.
If the motor is stopped and you press the button, it starts going but
in the opposite direction it was going before. If the motor is going upward and
you hit the button, it stops, leaving the door wherever it was at that time.
However, for security or safety reasons, if the motor's going downward and
you press the button, it not only stops but then it immediately turns on and
goes in the other direction. Presumably because something was detected that
might be damaged by the door going down on it. And implicit in this is
some sensors. One sensor determining whether the door is all the way up, and
another sensor saying whether the door is all the way down.